gleichzeitig in dieser lage ist ein
kopfgeld ausgesetzt auf russlands
präsident der russische geschäftsmann
alex konami schien der hat ein kopfgeld
von einer million dollar ausgesetzt auf
putin wer ist der mann der hat in den
90ern mal den wahlkampf von boris jelzin
finanziert lebt seit vielen vielen
jahren seit 1999 in den usa und setzt
jetzt ja ein kopfgeld auf den russischen
präsidenten aus darüber sprechen wir
jetzt mit peter tiede uns zugeschaltet
aus moskau wird er man muss sagen die
meisten menschen in russland haben gar
nicht den zugang zu medien zu einer eher
sagen wir mal objektiven
berichterstattung in diesem konflikt
beschreibe uns einmal wie die menschen
dort damit umgehen du hast ja auch mit
bildern konfrontiert wir sehen jetzt ein
kopfgeld wird ausgeschrieben das aber
vermutlich eine einzelaktion
schüler pr gag und eine martialische
geste aber in russland einfach mal zu
nichts führen also erstens wäre das zu
wenig für den link der da ist der das
macht was ist eine familie weil
überleben würde er das nicht gerade
putin lebt in einem begrenzten an
gepanzerten kokon er lebt in einer
panzer blase und aus diesem bezirk wird
sich auch niemand töten und ansonsten
sieht ja keiner zu gesicht ansonsten
müssen wir sagen dass hier die medien
noch weiter eingeschränkt werden man hat
er mal gedacht das geht gar nicht gar
nicht weiter 98 also mehr zu 98 prozent
der medien sind in staatshand oder die
gleichen einfachen die gleichen zutaten
putin halten aber selbst da wenn jetzt
schon baby wieder zugemacht echo moskwy
das ist eine radiostation die gehört
sogar zum gazprom-konzern die hat sich
geweigert das wort krieg aus der
berichterstattung rauszunehmen und die
haben wir relativ relativ muss man sagen
für russische verhältnisse unabhängig
berichtet dichtgemacht gestern also sind
nicht mehr zu empfangen hier in russland
außerhalb von russland kann man sie noch
empfangen das gleiche ist ist der tv
station dort passiert auch dies dicht
gemacht und die haben sogar richtig
berichtet über den krieg die haben auch
bilder veröffentlicht dicht gemacht
früher war das so da gab es erst
geldstrafen das zog sich dann manchmal
über 12 jahre hin bis zur verfügung zum
zum schließen kam oder zum nicht mehr
ausstrahlen jetzt geht das binden von
tagen oder binnen stunden also hier
kommt nichts weiter an es gibt einen
kleinen gegenschlag von von
ausländischen helfern mutmaßlich die
haben dafür dann die web seiten
angegriffen von kommersant das ist eine
staatliche zeitung oder ja alle nicht
nur unabhängige zeitung dann tatsächlich
auch von den staatsmedien rwk und von
ria nowosti und so was sind die
wichtigsten nachrichten agenturen und
newsportale dies in russland gibt die
waren heute morgen zumindest
haben wir heute morgen peter fotos
gesehen von kindern kindern hinter
gitter diese fotos gehen in den sozialen
medien rum auch du hast für uns
geschickt und auch das ist wieder ein
brutales zeichen der von putin an die
welt ausgetragen an unschuldigen kindern
wie er mit menschen die sich gegen ihn
wenden umgeht bericht uns mehr davon
dass das für ein verkommenes system ist
und wie das eigentlich in sich selber
wirklich auf dem zahnfleisch kriecht
aber noch genügend geld hat um noch
überall ins hinzukommen das sieht man
daran gestern abend wollten mütter mit
ihren kindern an der ukrainischen
botschaft hier im moskauer zentrum
blumen niederlegen und eine kleine
solidaritäts gäste machen sind verhaftet
worden den müttern sind die handys der
genommen den kindern auch es sind kinder
zwischen neun und elf jahren sie sind
alle im polizeigewahrsam in einer
berüchtigten polizeiwache im moskauer
zentrum und daran sieht man dass in
diesem land also so wie ich lade mir
putin nach außen nicht mehr an verträge
oder an recht und gesetz hält so hält er
sich in seinem land schon ganz ganz
lange nicht mehr daran das ist auch das
was mich immer jetzt schon über jahre
wütend gemacht hat wenn ich die die
putin unterstützer und die kreml
verstehe dann in deutschland gehört habe
die einfach weggesehen haben dieses land
wirklich
ausgefegt ausgemerzt worden ist wie
jeder wien jeder funke freiheit hier mit
wirklich mit ganzen armeen von
feuerwehren einfach immer wieder
erstickt worden ist und bekämpfen worden
ist wladimir putin nach der letzten
präsidentenwahl wirklich jeden rest von
von opposition hinweggefegt hat und dann
ja noch versucht hat
in der vali umzubringen und in
deutschland gab es immer noch leute die
das irgendwie verteidigt haben einen
russischen freunde die ihr ja nicht
buddhisten sind die haben immer mit
unverständnis darauf gelegt und diese
bilder die heute aus dem knast kommen
die die nowaja gaseta veröffentlicht hat
von kindern im gefängnis über nacht mit
ihren müttern abgeschnitten von
jeglicher kommunikation also weiter
sinken tiefer sinken kann so ein system
einfach nicht mehr dass uns diese bilder
bitte noch einmal zeigen weil das ist an
diesem morgen wirklich unfassbar das
sind kleine kinder peter tiede hat uns
das gerade beschrieben die in moskau
blumen als zeichen der solidarität
niederlegen wollten und die reaktion ist
dass diese kinder die nacht im gefängnis
verbringen das ihren müttern das handy
weggenommen dass die kinder die hier
noch mit ihren selbst gemalten
transparenten sitzen jetzt hinter
gittern sitzen was für ein zeichen peter
was für eine tat ja es ist einfach ein
unmenschliches system hier kennt kann
der kreml kennt keine gnade nach innen
nicht und nicht nach außen in der
ukraine werden mütter mit den kindern
vertrieben da werden extra die bilder
produziert damit angst und schrecken
verbreitet damit die mütter mit den
kindern von den vätern fliehen damit die
familien kiel verlassen dass die dass
die familien ihre heimat verlassen wir
haben gerade gesprochen in unserem hotel
mit einer deutschen die in dubai lebt
direkt hierher geflogen ist und mit dem
vater von zwei kindern zu reden die in
der ukraine noch mit der mutter waren
und um den vater zu helfen die mutter
wollte mit den kindern nicht raus weil
jetzt irland ist weil es weil es darum
geht ihre stadt zu verteidigen und die
haben jetzt auf den letzten metern
rausgekriegt und das wird verbreitet
nach außen angst und schrecken
vertreibung in der ukraine und hier
werden frauen mit ihren kindern ins
gefängnis gesteckt man kann es nicht
mehr anders sagen man kann wirklich
nicht tiefer sinken als wladimir putin
mit seinem system